This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In 2011, the race for US President was heating up. Near the front of the pack on the Republican side was Rick Perry. His odds look promising. He had been governor of Texas for more than a decade and the previous Republican President, George W. Bush, had also been a Texas governor. Rick Perry's poll numbers were competitive, and he had amassed an impressive
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。2011年，美国总统竞选正进入白热化阶段。在共和党阵营中，处于领先集团前列的是里克·佩里。他的胜算看起来很乐观。他担任德克萨斯州州长已超过十年，而前任共和党总统小布什也曾担任过德州州长。里克·佩里的民调支持率颇具竞争力，并且他还筹集了令人瞩目的
war chest. His core themes of shrinking government and cutting spending were popular with many Republican voters. Tonight we are here in the great state of Michigan for a debate that will focus almost exclusively on the economy. On November 9th, Rick Perry appeared on stage in Rochester, Michigan, along with seven fellow candidates. It was a live, televised debate, watched by millions. The moderator asked a question about what the candidates were doing office if elected. But to factor the matter is, we better have a plan in place that Americans can get their
竞选资金。他关于精简政府和削减开支的核心主张受到许多共和党选民的欢迎。今晚我们齐聚伟大的密歇根州，进行一场几乎完全聚焦于经济的辩论。11月9日，里克·佩里与另外七位候选人一同登上了罗切斯特的辩论舞台。这是一场现场电视辩论，有数百万观众收看。主持人提出了一个关于候选人如果当选将在任上做些什么的的问题。但事实是，我们最好制定一个美国人能够切实掌控的计划。
hands around. And that's the reason my flat tax is a Young Rick Perry launched energetically into a description of the actions he planned to take as president and his sweeping plans to slash the size of government under his leadership he vowed Entire departments would disappear and I will tell you It's three agencies of government when I get there that are gone. Commerce, education, and the, what's the third one there? Let's see. Commerce, education, and the...
这就是我的单一税制是一个年轻的里克·佩里充满活力地开始描述他计划作为总统采取的行动，以及他大幅削减政府规模的宏伟计划。在他的领导下，他发誓要让整个部门消失。当我上台时，会有三个政府部门彻底消失。商务部、教育部，还有，第三个是什么来着？让我想想。商务部、教育部，还有……
You can't name the third one? The third agency of government. I would do away with the education, the commerce, and let's see, I can't. The third one I can't, sorry. Oops. That oops on national TV helps sink Rick Perry's presidential aspirations. The former Massachusetts governor, Mitt Romney, was chosen as the Republican Party's nominee for president. This week on Hidden Brain, the mysteries of memory.
你想不出第三个吗？政府的第三个机构。我要废除教育部、商务部，让我想想，我想不起来了。第三个我想不起来了，抱歉。哎呀。这个在全美电视直播节目中的“哎呀”重创了里克·佩里的总统抱负。前马萨诸塞州州长米特·罗姆尼被选为共和党总统候选人。本周的《隐藏大脑》将探讨记忆的奥秘。
The first time he was in the U.S. was a former Massachusetts governor, Mitt Romney, and the first time he was in the U.S. was a former Massachusetts governor, Mitt Romney, was chosen as the Republican Party's nominee for president. This week on Hidden Brain, the mysteries of memory. How it works, why it fails us, and how to build memories that stick. So much of daily life depends on our memories, getting to important events on time, remembering a friend's birthday, executing skills in the workplace. But our memories often don't work the way we wish. Even in the absence of neurological disorders, perfectly healthy people find they forget
他第一次来到美国是前马萨诸塞州州长，米特·罗姆尼，而他第一次来到美国是前马萨诸塞州州长，米特·罗姆尼被选为共和党总统候选人。本周的《隐藏大脑》将探讨记忆的奥秘。它是如何运作的，为什么会让我们失效，以及如何建立持久的记忆。日常生活中有很大一部分依赖于我们的记忆：准时参加重要活动、记住朋友的生日、在职场中运用技能。但我们的记忆往往并不按照我们希望的方式工作。即使在没有神经系统疾病的情况下，完全健康的人也会发现自己
important things all the time. At the University of Virginia, psychologists Daniel Willingham has observed many lapses of memory in his own life. In his lab, he has studied different ways that our memory can fail us and how we can fix it. Dan Willingham, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much. Happy to be here. Dan, when you were a college student, you enrolled in a course, you were sure you were going to get an easy A in.
随时随地都在忘掉重要的事情。在弗吉尼亚大学，心理学家丹尼尔·威灵厄姆在自己的生活中观察到了许多记忆失误。在他的实验室里，他研究了记忆可能对我们失效的不同方式以及我们该如何修复它。丹·威灵厄姆，欢迎来到《隐藏大脑》。非常感谢。很高兴来到这里。丹，当你还是个大学生的时候，你选修了一门课，你确信自己肯定能轻松拿A。
What was this course, Dan? It was a physical anthropology course. I took this course solely because I thought it was going to be an easy A. And then it turned out eventually to be the lowest grade that I got in any college course. And did you, I'm assuming you must have gone and talked to the professor and tried to make your case as students I want to do. I did. And I said exactly what. Today my students say to me, I said, you know, I'm very confused. You know, I'm certain that I knew this content very well, and yet I did very poorly on your test. So I'm here to try to figure out how I can do better in your course,
这是什么课，丹？这是一门体质人类学课。我选这门课纯粹是因为我以为能轻松拿A。结果它最终成了我所有大学课程中得的分数最低的一门。而且你，我猜你肯定去找教授谈过，试图据理力争，就像学生们常做的那样。我确实去了。我说的话和我今天学生对我说的一样，我说：“你知道，我很困惑。你知道，我确信我对这些内容非常熟悉，然而我在你的测试中却考得很差。所以我来这里是想弄清楚如何在你的课程中表现得更好，”
which is really polite double talk for. That was a terrible test. It was really unfair. This, of course, did not fool the professor in the least. And he said, so you feel like you knew the content. I said, yes, absolutely. Said, okay, well, so for example, we talked about different categories of stone tools.
这其实是一套礼貌的官话，翻译过来就是：“那是一场糟糕透顶的测试。太不公平了。”这当然一点也没有愚弄到这位教授。他说：“所以你觉得自己很懂内容？”我说：“是的，绝对懂。”他说：“好吧，比如我们讨论过不同种类的石器。”
And you understood, yes, I absolutely understood. OK, so why don't you tell me about the different categories of stone tools? So I sputtered a bit. And then eventually said, well, I understand it. I just can't explain it. So there was sort of a mismatch between my perception of what my memory was like and what my memory was actually like in the context of the test.
你理解了吗？是的，我完全理解。好的，那你为什么不跟我讲讲不同种类的石器呢？”于是我结结巴巴地说了几句。最后我说：“嗯，我理解，我只是解释不出来。”所以，我对自己的记忆状况的感知与我在测试情境下实际的记忆状况之间存在某种不匹配。
You know, so psychologists sometimes call this the illusion of explanatory depth. We think we know things, but when challenge to actually produce that knowledge, we come up short. And this happens all the time to us, right, Dan? It really does. The way you would think that you would judge whether or not you know something is really just sort of look at your memory and see whether or not you know it, but it turns out there are a number of different ways we make this judgment. And so that's one of the ways you can go wrong is using the wrong cue to decide whether or not you know something. I want to bring up another incident that I think reveals a different way in which our memories can fail us. So after college you went on to graduate school and psychology and one day your advisor called a really big and important lab meeting one day. Tell me what happened.
你知道，心理学家有时称之为“解释深度的错觉”。我们以为自己懂很多东西，但当面临真正需要展示这些知识的挑战时，我们却拿不出来。这种情况随时都在发生在我们身上，对吧，丹？确实如此。你以为你判断自己是否懂某件事的方法，真的只是审视一下自己的记忆，看看自己记不记得，但事实证明，我们做出这种判断的方式有很多种。所以，你出错的原因之一就是用了错误的线索来决定自己是否懂某件事。我想提出另一个事件，我认为它揭示了我们的记忆失效的另一种方式。大学毕业后，你继续读心理学研究生，有一天，你的导师召开了一次非常盛大且重要的实验室会议。告诉我发生了什么。
Yeah. My advisor was a brilliant psychologist. He actually was a winner of the national medal of science. But he was rather forbidding. He was sort of known for very long pauses during conversations during which you had to assume he was thinking, but you didn't know what he was thinking. So yes, we were all pretty frightened of him. What happened was that I forgot about the meeting, and the irony was that the meeting was happening in sort of a bullpen area right outside my office door. So I had my office door closed.
是的。我的导师是一位杰出的心理学家。他实际上是国家科学奖章的获得者。但他相当令人敬畏。他以在谈话中出现非常长的停顿而闻名，在这些停顿中，你必须假设他正在思考，但你不知道他在想什么。所以是的，我们都很怕他。事情是这样的，我把会议给忘了，而具有讽刺意味的是，会议就在我办公室门外的一个公共办公区举行。所以我当时把办公室门关着。
I was happily, you know, reading or I don't know what in the world I was doing. But the lab meeting was happening 10 feet away from me and I expect they were saying, you know, where's Willingham? What's what? I just had no idea. So yeah, that's a failure of what psychologists call prospective memory where you're planning to remember something. And in this case, obviously failing dreadfully to remember it. I almost hesitate to ask, did you hear from your advisor about it? Yes, I went to talk to him about it and the duration of the time between I said something about it and he responded was probably 20 seconds or something during which I was squirming. And he did say, oh, it's OK, it happens to all of us,
我正高高兴兴地，你知道，在读书，或者我不知道当时在忙什么。但实验室会议就在离我10英尺远的地方举行，我猜他们当时一定在说：“威灵厄姆去哪儿了？怎么回事？”我完全不知道。所以，是的，这就是心理学家所说的前瞻性记忆失效，也就是你计划去记住某事。而在这个例子中，很明显，你糟糕透顶地没能记住它。我几乎不敢问，你导师找你谈这事了吗？是的，我去找他谈过这件事，从我提及此事到他回应之间的时间大约有20秒左右，这期间我在坐立不安。他的确说过：“哦，没关系，这种事我们都会遇到，”
but it was extremely uncomfortable. Now, lots of us feel that some memories are immune from lapses. When we learn something well, we feel, OK, I've got this. In your first year of teaching down, you were explaining a basic concept and statistics to a class of students. What were you trying to teach
但这极其令人尴尬。现在，许多人觉得有些记忆是不会失效的。当我们把某事学得很透彻时，我们会觉得：“行了，我掌握了。”丹，在你教书的第一年，你正在向一班学生解释统计学的一个基本概念。你当时想教什么？
and tell me what happened? Yeah, a very basic sort of, I was probably the second week of class, I think. I was teaching about skewness of distributions. So many of your listeners probably are familiar with the bell-shaped curve. So curves can not only be bell-shaped, they can be kind of fat at one end and then
能告诉我发生了什么吗？是的，是非常基础的一种，可能是我上课的第二周吧。我当时在教分布的偏态。所以你们很多听众可能对钟形曲线很熟悉。曲线不仅可以是钟形的，一头还可以比较胖，而
skinny at the other and that skinny part might be on the left or on the right. And so this is referred to as the skewness of the distribution and we talk about a distribution having either a positive or a negative skew depending on which side is fat and which is skinny. And I could not, while I'm teaching this undergraduate course, I just blanked on which was positive and which was negative. And you can't get much more elementary than that, but yeah, I just lost it. And of course, the more I tried to think about it, the more uncertain I became, and it just evaded me. So embarrassing failures of memory can happen in small private interactions and also on very big
另一头比较瘦，那个瘦的部分可能在左边，也可能在右边。这就被称为分布的偏态，我们根据哪一边胖、哪一边瘦，来讨论分布具有正偏态还是负偏态。而我在教这个本科生课程时，就是想不起来哪边是正，哪边是负。没有什么比这更初级的了，但是的，我就是卡壳了。当然，我越是努力去想，就越是不确定，它就是从我脑子里溜走了。所以，令人尴尬的记忆失误不仅会发生在微小的私人互动中，也会发生在非常大型的
public stages. And in some cases, the costs of these memory breakdowns can be far worse than an awkward moment. They can actually be astronomical. I want you to listen to this news report from 2021. San Francisco residents, Stefan Thomas, lost the key to unlock his digital wallet that holds 7,000 bitcoins. That translates to a whopping $220 million. The correct password is locked in a hard drive that gives users 10 guesses before it locks forever. Thomas has only two more
公开舞台上。在某些情况下，这些记忆崩溃的代价可能比一个尴尬的时刻糟糕得多。它们实际上可能是天文数字。我想请大家听听这段2021年的新闻报道。旧金山居民斯特凡·托马斯弄丢了打开其数字钱包的密钥，里面存有7000枚比特币。折合下来高达2.20亿美元。正确的密码被锁在一个硬盘里，该硬盘允许用户尝试10次猜测，之后就会永久锁定。托马斯只剩下最后两次
tries to gain access to his fortune. So Stefan Thomas never did remember his password then. Can you imagine what it must feel like to not remember a password that leads to a gigantic fortune? It's like being locked out of your own life. Yeah, I mean, I've never had a gigantic fortune, so I am sort of, I'm getting a little fanciful here in imagining it. But yeah, certainly we've all been there in terms of forgetting passwords. This happens to everybody these days. But what is startling is his confidence that he was going to remember this. Our judgment of our memory is often faulty. I vaguely remember writing the password down, putting it somewhere safe.
机会来获取他的财富。所以斯特凡·托马斯最终还是没想起他的密码。你能想象记不起一个通往巨额财富的密码是什么感觉吗？就像被锁在了你自己的生活之外。是的，我的意思是，我从来没有过巨额财富，所以我有点，我在想象时有点异想天开。但确实，我们在忘记密码这方面都深有体会。这几天每个人都会遇到这种事。但令人震惊的是，他之前竟然如此自信自己一定能记住。我们对记忆的判断往往是有缺陷的。我隐约记得自己把密码写下来了，放在了某个安全的地方。
Unfortunately, I think the chances of me just remembering the password are unfortunately very slow. Stefan Thomas is not alone. Some cryptocurrency experts estimate that around 20% of Bitcoin holdings worldwide appear to be in lost or otherwise stranded wallets. So why does memory let us down when we most depend on it? When we come back, counterintuitive truths about how memory works. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
不幸的是，我觉得我能凭记忆想起密码的几率非常低。斯特凡·托马斯并不孤单。一些加密货币专家估计，全球大约20%的比特币资产似乎都存放在丢失或无法访问的钱包里。那么，为什么在我们最依赖记忆的时候，它却让我们失望了？稍后我们将为您揭晓关于记忆运作机制的直觉反常真相。您正在收听的是《隐藏大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
At the University of Virginia, Dan Willingam studies why our memories fail us and how we can become better learners. Dan, in most domains of our lives, we all believe our intentions shape our outcomes. If I want something badly enough, I will take the steps to make it happen. I understand yet you were in graduate school when you first grappled with the question of whether this principle works when it comes to memory. Does our wanting to remember something help us to remember it? It is amazing. It has literally no impact at all in that there are things that we really want to remember. For example, the key to our
在弗吉尼亚大学，丹·威灵厄姆研究我们的记忆为什么会失效，以及我们如何才能成为更好的学习者。丹，在我们生活的绝大多数领域，我们都相信意愿决定结果。如果我足够渴望某件事，我就会采取行动让它发生。但我了解到，你当年在读研究生时，首次开始纠结这样一个问题：当涉及到记忆时，这个原则是否管用？我们想要记住某件事的愿望，能帮我们记住它吗？这太神奇了。它实际上没有任何影响，因为有些事情我们真的非常想记住。例如，我们的
Bitcoin or any time you meet someone you would really like to remember their name right. And of course we know we very often don't. And then too there are so many things that you remember that you never had any intention of remembering much less have any interest in remembering. So that should give us a little bit of a clue. And laboratory experiments back this up, you can tell people, listen, your memory is going to be probed later or not tell them that. And it has no impact on whether or not they eventually remember something. You know, you said something really interesting a second ago which is that it's not just
比特币密钥，或者任何时候当你遇到某个人，你真的很想记住他们的名字，对吧。当然，我们知道我们经常记不住。另一方面，有太多事情你明明从来没有想过去记住，更不用说对记住它们有任何兴趣了，但你却偏偏记住了。这应该能给我们提供一点线索。实验室的实验也证实了这一点，你可以告诉人们：“听好了，等会儿要测试你们的记忆，”或者不告诉他们。这对于他们最终是否能记住某事没有任何影响。你知道，刚才你说了非常有趣的一点，那就是：我们不仅
the case that we fail to remember things that we want to remember but that we regularly remember things that we don't care to remember. So there's something really strange going on here which is that our memories don't care to remember. So there's something really strange going on here, which is that our memories don't seem to follow, you know, our volition, our intention. They seem to have, you know, almost a mind of their own, you know, in some ways. What is it about the nature of the brain, Dan, that makes our intentions to remember something not matter very, but it seems to make a certain amount of evolutionary sense that this would not be a great way to set up a brain because our judgment in the moment may not be very good. So your memory system sort of lays its bets in a different way. It doesn't store what it is that you think ought to be stored. And instead, whatever it is you think about a whole lot, it's probably something you're
记不住那些我们想要记住的事情，而且还经常记住那些我们根本不在乎的事情。所以这里面发生了一些非常奇怪的事情，那就是我们的记忆似乎并不在意记住什么。所以这里面发生了一些非常奇怪的事情，那就是我们的记忆似乎并不遵循我们的意志或意图。在某些方面，它们似乎几乎拥有了自己的思想。丹，大脑的什么特性使得我们记住某事的意愿变得不那么重要，但从进化的角度来看，这似乎在某种程度上又是合乎情理的，因为我们在当下的判断可能并不是很好。所以你的系统会以另一种方式下注。它不会存储你认为应该存储的东西。相反，无论你满脑子在想什么，那大概率都是你需要再次思考的事情。因此，这就增加了它最终进入记忆系统的概率。
going to have to think about again. And so that increases the probability that it's going to end up in the memory system. Hmm. So from an evolutionary point of view, the argument you're making here is that if something is occupying our mind, then it's in some ways reasonable and logical to infer that that thing must be important, and therefore it makes sense in some ways to devote the resources of memory to actually preserving the thing that we're thinking about. That's exactly it.
嗯。所以从进化的角度来看，你在这里提出的观点是：如果某件事占据了我们的大脑，那么在某种程度上，推断这件事一定很重要是合理且符合逻辑的，因此，将记忆资源奉献给真正保存我们正在思考的事物，在某些方面就变得合情合理了。正是如此。
And there are, when we say occupy your mind, we need to be precise about what that would mean, because there are different ways your mind can we need to be precise about what that would mean because there are different ways your mind can be occupied. You can be thinking about something for a long period of time, but thinking about it in a pretty shallow sort of robotic way, and that's not going to be very good for memory, or you can think about something briefly, but in a really deep way where you're thinking about what it means, you're connecting it to other things that you know, and that's going to be really good for memory. Now, a second assumption that we make about memory is that
而且，当我们说“占据你的大脑”时，我们需要对这意味着什么有精确的理解，因为你的大脑被占据的方式有很多种。你可以长时间思考某件事，但只是用一种相当浅薄、机械的方式去思考，这对记忆并没有多大帮助；或者你可以短暂地思考某件事，但却用一种非常深入的方式，去思考它的含义，将它与你已经知道的其他事物联系起来，这对记忆将大有裨益。现在，关于记忆的第二个假设是：
developing a pleasing sense of familiarity with the material will allow us to remember it later. So, you know, I feel that this happens all the time as well. You have to give a speech and you read over your script 20 times until you feel confident you have it. You see this confidence may be a secret enemy when it comes to memory. Why is that then? Yeah, because that confidence is coming from familiarity
对材料培养出一种愉悦的熟悉感，就能让我们在以后记住它。所以，你知道，我觉得这种事经常发生。你必须做一个演讲，于是你把稿子读了20遍，直到你觉得有把握背下来了。你会发现，这种自信在涉及记忆时可能是一个秘密敌人。丹，这是为什么呢？是的，因为这种自信来自于熟悉感，
and familiarity is not exactly the same type of memory that you usually want. So familiarity is the sense that I have encountered this before, and you can make that judgment very rapidly. Other connected information is usually retrieved more slowly and will take a little bit more effort. So for example, you may see someone on the street and think, oh, they look familiar. And then you can't quite place them. So you start trying to
而熟悉感并不完全等同于你通常想要的记忆类型。熟悉感是指“我以前遇到过这个”的感觉，你可以非常迅速地做出这种判断。而其他相关信息的检索通常较慢，需要付出更多一点的努力。例如，你可能会在街上看到某个人，心想：“哦，他们看起来好面熟。”然后你又一时想不起他是谁。于是你开始试图
think, do I know them from work? Do they go to a shop that I go to? And what you're essentially doing is generating memory cues to try to help you get more information about who this person is and place them. So we're used to this idea that there is often this very quick sense of familiarity and then there may be more information in there but we're going to have to dig for it. So this is where familiarity can lead you astray. We're used to the idea that familiarity is often followed by other information, if we put in a little bit more effort. It could be, there is no other information. And so, as you're preparing for that speech, all you've done is by reading it over and over and over again, is give yourself a very strong sense of familiarity, but you're not actually
去想：“我是通过工作认识他们的吗？他们去我去的那家店吗？”你本质上在做的事情是生成记忆线索，试图帮助自己获取关于这个人的更多信息并对号入座。所以我们已经习惯了这样一种观点：通常会有一种非常快速的熟悉感，接着可能会有更多信息涌现，但我们需要去深挖。这就是熟悉感可能把你带偏的地方。我们习惯了这种观念：如果我们再多付出一 点努力，熟悉感通常会伴随着其他信息。但也有可能，根本没有其他信息。因此，当你为那场演讲做准备时，你反反复复阅读所做的一切，仅仅是给了自己一种非常强烈的熟悉感，但你实际上
able to remember the speech, which is what you're going to need to be able to do later. What is the alternative strategy to reading a speech 20 times and feeling confident that we have memorized it? Engage the mental processes that you're actually going to need at the time. So what you're going to want to do is to be able to give the speech with only occasional reference to your notes. So you need to practice giving the speech with only occasional reference to your notes.
并没有能力把演讲内容背出来，而这正是你稍后需要做到的。把演讲稿读20遍并盲目自信已经背熟了，除此之外的替代策略是什么？去动用你在实际需要时真正要用到的心理过程。所以你要做的是，练习在仅偶尔参考笔记的情况下发表这篇演讲。因此，你需要练习只凭偶尔参考笔记来发表这篇演讲。
The thing about that, of course, is that's going to be harder, and it's going to feel like you're failing a lot more frequently. But this is what you actually need to do and this is that's what's going to be best for memory. You know, I'm thinking that when we are trying to learn something very often when we look back at the material in a textbook, for example, and we say, yeah, I'm familiar with it, that looks, that looks right. I know what that is. Partly what we're doing is we're reassuring ourselves that we know the material. And I think what I'm hearing you say is that a better strategy,
当然，这样做的问题在于，它会更难，而且会让你觉得失败的频率要高得多。但这正是你实际需要做的，也是对记忆最好的方法。你知道我在想，当我们试图学习某样东西时，很多时候当我们回看教科书上的材料，然后说：“是的，我很熟悉，看起来对，我知道那是什么。”部分原因是我们是在自我安慰，让自己觉得我们懂这些材料。我想我听到你的意思是，一个更好的策略——
though perhaps more unpleasant, is to actually try and unearth the specific places in our knowledge where we are actually lacking. So rather than trying to show us prove to ourselves that we know the material, to actually prove to ourselves where we don't know the material, to actually prove to ourselves where we don't know the material, our weaknesses, can tell us where to focus.
尽管可能不太愉快——是去真正试着找出我们知识中具体缺失的地方。因此，与其向自己证明我们懂这些材料，不如向自己证明我们在哪里不懂这些材料，向自己证明我们在哪里不懂这些材料，我们的弱点可以告诉我们应该把重点放在哪里。
I think that's exactly right. You need to test yourself, see what you know and what you don't know, and then work on the part that you don't know. It sounds very obvious when you've explicated it the way you have, but even though it sounds obvious when you say it's something that most people don't do. I remember talking to Angela Duckworth many years ago after she wrote her book on grit, and one of her studies was looking at Spelling Bee Champions, and the thing that she found
我觉得这完全正确。你需要测试自己，看看自己懂什么，不懂什么，然后针对不懂的部分进行练习。当你用这种方式阐述时，这听起来显而易见，但尽管听起来显而易见，大多数人却并不会这样做。很多年前，安吉拉·达克沃斯在写完关于坚毅的书后，我曾与她交谈过，她的其中一项研究是调查拼写比赛冠军。她发现的是：
was that Spelling Bee Champions, you know, obviously put in a lot of time in preparation, but they also did what she called deliberate practice. And the way she defined deliberate practice was very similar to what you're talking about, Dan, which is it was a process of deliberately trying to identify areas of weakness and focus on those areas of weakness. And of course, that has to be very unpleasant and difficult to do. Absolutely, and this is one of the things that define people with grit, is that they're able to face up to these sorts of difficult tasks and focus on one thing at a time.
拼写比赛的冠军们，当然在准备上投入了大量时间，但他们也进行了她所谓的“刻意练习”。她对刻意练习的定义与你所谈论的非常相似，丹，也就是：这是一个刻意尝试找出薄弱环节并专注于这些薄弱环节的过程。当然，这一定非常令人不快且难以做到。绝对是的，这也是定义具备坚毅品质的人的特征之一：他们能够直面这些困难的任务，并且一次专注于一件事。
And so, okay, this particular passage of this piece of music I'm trying to learn, this is what I'm really having difficulty with. And in addition, the other aspect of deliberate practice that's really important is thinking of strategies to overcome this difficulty, you know, being ready to be creative and try different things and experiment to see how you can overcome the problem. A third assumption we make about memory is that once we know something, we know it, that our work is done.
所以，“好吧，我试图学习的这段音乐的这个特定乐段，正是我真正感到困难的地方。”此外，刻意练习的另一个非常重要的方面是思考克服这一困难的策略，你知道的，准备好发挥创造力，尝试不同的方法，并通过实验来看看你如何能克服这个难题。关于记忆的第三个假设是：一旦我们懂了某件事，我们就掌握了，我们的工作就完成了。
But of course, knowing something doesn't protect us from the fact that there is a silent process that can chip away at what we know. Can you talk about this, that we imagine we know things, but we often underestimate our capacity to forget them. This is a really peculiar aspect of memory and we imagine that the state of our memory now will continue to be the state of our memory in the future. So we completely discount forgetting. And curiously, we do the same thing even when we plan on studying more. So in the experiments, what they'll do is they'll bring people in, they'll have them learn something, and it's something that people have no familiarity with at all. It will be like English to Swahili translation of vocabulary or something. And they'll say, okay, well, you've studied these 20 words, you're getting about 80% correct. I want you to go home, come back in two weeks, we're going to do the same thing again. By the way, how do you think you'll do when you come back for the first time? And people say, well, getting 80 percent, I guess, I'll probably get 80 percent again. They just completely discount that forgetting will happen in
但当然，懂某件事并不能保护我们免受这样一个事实的影响：有一个无声的过程正在侵蚀我们所了解的知识。你能谈谈这一点吗？我们以为自己懂得很多事情，但我们往往低估了自己遗忘它们的能力。这是记忆一个非常奇特的地方，我们总觉得我们现在记忆的状态在未来也会保持下去。因此我们完全忽视了遗忘。奇怪的是，哪怕在我们计划进行更多学习时，我们也会这样做。在实验中，他们会把人们请来，让他们学习一些完全不熟悉的东西。比如英语到斯瓦希里语的词汇翻译之类的东西。他们会说：“好了，你们已经学完了这20个单词，你们的正确率大约是80%。我希望你们回家，两周后再来，我们将重复同样的测试。顺便说一句，你们觉得第一次回来时自己能考多少分？”人们会说：“嗯，既然正确率是80%，我想我大概还能考80%吧。”他们完全忽视了在这两周里会发生遗忘。根据我对学生的经验，
those two weeks. And in my experience with my students, once you point this out and explain it, it's not difficult for them to understand, but people just don't think about it if you don't point it out. So you see that one way to counteract this inevitable process of forgetting is not just to learn, but to over-learn the material we're trying to remember. What does this look like then? Over-learning means continuing to rehearse and practice some content that you want to learn, even when it seems to you, you know it perfectly well. So, suppose you're working with flashcards or something with our English Sweehili translation,
一旦你指出这一点并向他们解释，他们并不难理解，但如果你不主动指出，人们根本不会去想它。所以你发现，对抗这种不可避免的遗忘过程的一个方法，不仅是去学习，还要对我们试图记住的材料进行“过度学习”。丹，这具体是什么样子的？过度学习意味着继续排练和练习某些你想学习的内容，哪怕在你看来你已经把它掌握得滚瓜烂熟了。假设你正在使用抽认卡或者我们刚才说的英语-斯瓦希里语翻译，
and you're getting them right every time you're running through the list of flashcards, you're just killing it. Overlearning says, keep going. And you can imagine that as you're doing that, you're just killing it. Overlearning says, keep going. And you can imagine that as you're doing that, you would think, what is the point of this? I'm getting them all right, I know it. But what you're doing in this process of overlearning
而且你每次翻阅抽认卡列表时都答对了，简直是游刃有余。过度学习的意思是：继续下去。你可以想象，当你这样做的时候，你可能会想：“这有什么意义？我全都答对了，我懂了。”但在过度学习这个过程中你所做的是：
is you're protecting against forgetting. So you spend many years studying how memory works and studying how to fix lapses in memory. And then you say, okay, let me go out and teach my students, you know, how to learn better, how to be better students. And of course, you're an educator. So it's the perfect setting because students want to learn and remember, you know, the things that they have learned.
你在防范遗忘。所以你花了多年时间研究记忆是如何运作的，研究如何修复记忆中的漏洞。然后你说：“好吧，让我去教我的学生，你知道的，如何更好地学习，如何成为更好的学生。”当然，你是一名教育工作者。所以这是个完美的场景，因为学生们想要学习并记住他们所学的东西。
Tell me about your efforts to teach these ideas to your students. Did they master your insights and start to remember things better? It really didn't work out the way I thought it was going to work out. I started by talking to the students who were coming to see me because they were unhappy with their progress in my course. And I asked them a lot of detailed questions about, well, what are you doing now and like
跟我讲讲你向学生传授这些理念的努力。他们掌握了你的见解并开始更好地记住事情了吗？事情的发展真的和我预想的不一样。我一开始是和那些因为对我在课上的进度不满意而主动来找我的学生交谈。我问了他们很多详细的问题，比如：“你现在在做什么？把你的笔记拿来，让我们看看”等等。所以我当时觉得自己挺擅长诊断每个学生身上到底出了什么问题。我给他们提出了这些建议，他们也连连点头，看起来全盘接受了。但我查看了他们的成绩，发现他们并没有进步。所以我对此感到非常困惑。
bringing your notes and let's look at them so on. And so I felt like I was getting pretty good at diagnosing what was going on with each individual student. And I was dispensing this advice, and they were nodding and looking like they were taking it all in. And I monitored their grades, and I found that they were not improving. So I was very puzzled by this.
所以在经历大约一年的这种情况后，我开始对这些学生进行回访，问他们：“所以我们之前谈过，告诉我，你照我建议的做了吗？”我发现一个非常普遍的回答是：“我试过了，但感觉太蠢了。一点也不觉得有效。”所以我后来就不这么做了。所以在某种程度上，那些有效的方法感觉上并不有效。因此凭直觉，人们无法坚持下去。完全正确。
So after about a year of that, I started following up with those students and saying, so we had this conversation, tell me, did you do what I suggested you do? And I found a very common response was, I tried it and it just felt stupid. It just didn't feel like it was effective at all. And so I stopped doing it. So in some ways, the things that were effective don't feel like they're effective. And so intuitively, people don't stick to it. That's exactly right.
这与我发现并非常感兴趣的另一个现象有关，那就是：学生在K-12（中小学）阶段并没有被教导应该如何学习、如何做笔记、以及在学校里需要做的所有不同事情。他们当然也没有被教导他们的记忆是如何运作的。然而，他们似乎都采用了相同的策略来进行记忆。原因在于：他们都不约而同地倾向于那些在当下感觉有效且不太费力的策略。那些能够增强我们记忆的策略，感觉并不令人满足或富有成效。
It's connected to another phenomenon that I discovered and was very interested in, which is that students are not taught in K through 12 how they should study, how to take notes, all the different things they're going to need to do in school. And they're certainly not taught about how their memory works. And yet they all seem to use the same strategies for memorization. And the reason is they all gravitate towards strategies that feel effective in the moment, and that also aren't that difficult. The strategies that work to strengthen our memory don't feel satisfying or productive.
所以我们抛弃了它们，转而采用那些感觉正确、但通常效率低下甚至适得其反的策略。就像弹簧恢复原形一样，我们又回到了简单直观的假设上，尽管这些假设往往是错误的。稍后我们将探讨：如何赢得与自我的战斗，并开始践行科学揭示的、真正让我们的记忆变得更强大的艰难真相。您正在收听的是《隐藏大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。丹·威灵厄姆是弗吉尼亚大学的认知科学家。
So we discard them in favour of strategies that feel right, but are often less effective or even counterproductive. Like a spring reverting to its old shape, we revert to our easy intuitive assumptions, even though those assumptions are often wrong. When we come back, how to win the battle with ourselves and start to practice the hard truths uncovered by science that actually make our memories stronger. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Dan Willingham is a cognitive scientist at the University of Virginia.
他研究记忆的运作方式及其失效原因。丹也是《超越大脑：为什么学习很难以及如何让它变得简单》（Outsmart Your Brain）一书的作者。丹，我们已经看到科学是如何对增强记忆产生深刻见解的。问题在于，我们大多数人并没有使用这些见解，因为它们感觉并不令人满意，也不轻松。你用体能锻炼来做类比，帮助人们理解你关于创造持久记忆所需付出的努力的观点。做俯卧撑和拥有更好的记忆力之间有什么联系？
He studies how memory works and how it fails. Dan is also the author of the book, Outsmart Your Brain, while learning is hard and how you can make it easy. Dan we've seen how science has come up with insights into strengthening memory. The problem is that most of us don't use these insights because they don't feel satisfying or easy. You draw an analogy with physical exercise to help people understand your point about the kind of effort that's necessary to create lasting memories. What's the connection between doing push ups and having a better memory?
是的，想象一下，你有一个朋友正在努力增强体力，他们希望能够做成百上千个俯卧撑。有一次你去拜访他们，看到他们在训练，结果发现他们在膝盖着地做俯卧撑。你会说：“这到底是为了什么？如果你想做标准的俯卧撑，你就应该做标准的俯卧撑。事实上，与其做普通的俯卧撑，你还不如做那种难度极高的俯卧撑，比如那种把自己从地板上撑起来并击掌的俯卧撑。”
Yes, so imagine that you've got a friend who is trying to gain strength and they want to be able to do lots and lots of push-ups. So you go and visit them one time and see them training and you find them doing push-ups on their knees. And you say, why in the world, like if you want to do a lot of regular push-ups, you should do regular push-ups. In fact, instead of regular push-ups, you should do really difficult push-ups, like the ones where you launch yourself off the floor
你的朋友说：“是啊，已经有几个人跟我这么说过了，我也试过，但我几乎一个都做不出来。这里的重点是，我在努力做很多个俯卧撑，对吧？你看，当我膝盖着地做俯卧撑时，我能以极快的速度做很多个。”
and clap. And your friend says, yeah, a couple of people have told me that and I tried it, but like I could hardly do any of those push ups. And the whole point here is I'm trying to do a lot of push ups, right? So, but look, when I do push ups on my knees, I can do so many so quickly.
所以这其实是同一回事。很多时候，当人们试图把事情记在心里时，他们做的是俯卧撑的心理等效版——膝盖着地版。他们做的是那些在当下感觉有效且做起来轻松的事情。但当然，你需要挑战。而且这必须是正确的挑战。不能只是随便什么挑战，正确的挑战才能在长远给你带来收益。
So it's sort of the same thing. A lot of times when people are trying to commit things to memory, they're doing the mental equivalent of push-ups on their knees. They're doing things that feel effective in the moment and also feel easy. But of course you need the challenge. And of course it has to be the right type of challenge. Can't just be any challenge, but the right type of challenge is going to bring you the benefit in the long run.
让我们来听听那些能把你从地板上弹起并击掌足够长时间的俯卧撑的心理替代品。你已经解释过，我们对某条信息的记忆与我们围绕该信息所进行的心理活动有关。这一见解在制定记忆保持策略方面有什么含义？因此，你能做的最好的事情之一就是组织你试图学习的信息。记忆喜欢意义。当事物对我们有意义时，这意味着你试图学习的所有零星碎片都是相互连接的，这样当你记住其中的一部分时，它就会帮助你把其余部分给挖掘出来。
So let's hear about some of the mental equivalence of doing push-ups that propel you off the floor long enough to clap. You've explained that our memory for a piece of information is related to the mental activities we engage in around that information. What is the implication of this insight in terms of devising a memory retention strategy? So one of the best things you can do is organize the information that you're trying to learn. Memory loves meaning. When things are meaningful to us, that means that all the bits and pieces of what you're trying to learn are connected to one another so that when you remember part of it, that's going to help dredge up the rest of it.
然后，还要把它和你已经了解的事情联系起来。这同样很有帮助，相当于把它整合到更广泛的记忆网络中。这将是非常有帮助的。所以，去思考某事为什么是对的，而不只是：“好吧，我记住了这个事实、这个事实和这个事实”，而是努力寻找一种方法将它们组织起来、相互连接。
And then also connecting it to things that you already know something about. That's also helpful, sort of integrating it into sort of the broader memory web. It's going to be really helpful. So thinking about why something is true, not just, you know, okay, I've got this fact and this fact and this fact, trying to find a way to organize them to connect them to one another.
而且很多时候，我刚刚给出的那个建议有点难以遵循，显得有点模糊。这就好像是：“去思考意义。”你的大脑并不适合单纯去执行这样的指令。如果你给自己一个具体的任务，它的运作效果会好得多。所以，问问自己为什么某事是对的，或者如何去做某件事，这更有可能引导你走向思考其含义的道路。好吧，在某种程度上，这与这样一个想法有关：如果我只是阅读教科书，那可能不如阅读教科书、进行思考，然后实际去写和做围绕着
And then a lot of times that device I've just given is a little bit hard to follow, it's a little vague. It's like, think about meaning. Your brain is not set up to just sort of follow a command like that. It works much better if you give yourself a concrete task. So asking yourself why something is true or how to do something, that's more likely to sort of lead you down this path about thinking about what it means. All right, and in some ways this is connected to the idea that if I'm just reading a textbook that might not be as effective as reading the textbook thinking about it and then actually having to write and exercise that is built around you know
该章节中的教训的练习来得有效，因为这实际上在促使我自问：“我该如何自己把这些 ideas（理念）连接起来？我对这一节中整体理念的含义、整体理念的全貌是否有一个有凝聚力的画面？”完全正确。我将从两个方面来详细阐述你刚才所说的话。一是当你提到在阅读时思考意义时，我们都有过这样的阅读体验：基本上，在这种情况下，我们的眼睛只是在材料上飘过。
the lessons in that in that section because it's actually causing me now to say how can I connect the ideas myself and do I have sort of a cohesive picture of the whole of the whole idea the meaning of the idea that's in that section? That's absolutely right. And I'll elaborate on what you just said in two ways. One is when you said thinking about meaning while you're reading, we've all had the experience of reading, which basically, in this case, is sort of our eyes drifting over the material.
当你读到页面底部时，你突然意识到：“我刚才一直在想午饭吃什么。我根本没在想这些内容，对吧？”所以，甚至连这种状态的温和版也会发生：是的，你可能在思考它，但并没有那么深入，对吧？所以另一件事是——这非常普遍，有大量研究表明——人们在阅读时，逐句理解是没有问题的，但他们没有做很多的是跨句子的意义协调，以及跨段落的意义协调。好吧，
You get to the bottom of a page and you realize, I've been thinking about lunch. I've not been thinking about this content at all, right? And so even a softer version of that can happen where, yeah, you're sort of thinking about it, but not all that deeply, right? So the other thing is, and this is very common, there are lots of studies showing this, that one of the things that people do is they're reading and they're understanding sentence by sentence, but what they're not doing a lot of is coordinating meaning across sentences and coordinating meaning across paragraphs. Okay,
结合我刚刚读完的内容，这一段是什么意思？而你刚才建议的那种小型心理练习——比如“让我想想这是什么意思，看看我能否为这一节写个总结，看看我正在读的这本书的小标题，看看作者为什么要选这个小标题”——正是这种事情，它会促使你在句子和段落之间进行意义的协调。这对记忆将大有裨益。你指出，许多好心办坏事的课堂练习并没有真正引导学生以一种创造持久记忆的方式去思考材料。你能给我们讲讲你听说过的那位老师吗？他试图让学生去了解
what does this paragraph mean in light of what I just finished reading? And the little sort of mental exercise you just suggested, like let me think about what this means. Let me see if I can create a summary of this section. Let me look at the subheading for this book that I'm reading and see why the author chose that subheading. That's the kind of thing that's going to encourage you to do this coordination of meaning across sentences and paragraphs. And That's going to be great for memory. You've pointed out that many well-intentioned classroom exercises don't actually lead students to think about the material in a way that creates lasting memories. Can you tell us about the teacher you heard about who was trying to get students to learn
19世纪帮助被奴役者获得自由的秘密地下铁路网络？是的，实际上我观察过这堂课。这是针对小学中期学生，也就是四年级学生关于地下铁路的一堂课。这位老师试图向他们强调的一点是，那些试图逃跑的人所面临的不确定性，不仅体现在被追捕的危险上，还体现在诸如“你去哪里找食物？你怎么旅行？”等方面。所以这位老师实际做的是让他们烤饼干，因为这显然是当时的一种主食。
about the secret network that carried enslaved people to freedom in the 19th century? Yeah, this was actually I observed this lesson. So this was a lesson for middle elementary student, fourth grade, in the underground railroad. And one of the things that teacher was trying to emphasize to them was the uncertainty for these people trying to make their escape, not only in terms of being pursued and the danger of it, but also like, where are you going to get food and how are you going to travel and so on. And so what the teacher did was actually have them bake biscuits because this was apparently a mainstay food.
关于19世纪运送奴役人员获得自由的秘密网络？是的，实际上我观摩了这节课。这是一堂面向小学中年级（四年级）关于地下铁路的课。老师试图向他们强调的一点是，这些试图逃亡的人所面临的不确定性，不仅体现在被追捕和危险上，还体现在诸如你将从哪里获得食物、如何出行等等。因此，老师实际上让他们烤饼干，因为这显然是当时的主食。
And the students probably spent about 30 seconds thinking about the relationship between biscuits and the content, what this had to do with the Underground Railroad. And they probably spent about 20 or 30 minutes thinking about measuring flour, cutting shortening, and so on. So what I tell teachers is, listen, students don't remember what they want to remember. They certainly don't remember what their teachers want them to remember. They remember what they think about. So if they're spending most of their time thinking about how to bake biscuits, that's what they're going to get out of the lesson plan.
学生们可能花了大约30秒的时间思考饼干与内容的关系，思考这与地下铁路有什么关系。他们大概花了20到30分钟去思考量面粉、切起酥油等等。所以我告诉老师们：听着，学生不会记住他们想要记住的东西。他们当然也不会记住老师希望他们记住的东西。他们记住的是他们思考的内容。因此，如果他们大部分时间都在想怎么烤饼干，那他们从这堂课里学到的就会是这个。
How do you think the lesson plan should have been changed to get a better outcome? I think in this case, if the goal was to get the students to think about the practical aspects of what it would be like to try and escape via the underground railroad, something where they encourage them to think about, okay, here are your resources. Here are all of the dangers that are facing what do you suppose people did in these circumstances. How do you think they solve this problem?
你觉得应该如何修改这堂课来取得更好的效果？我认为在这种情况下，如果目标是让学生思考通过地下铁路逃亡时的实际情况，那就应该鼓励他们去思考：好了，这里是你们的资源。这里有你们面临的所有危险，你觉得当时的人们会怎么做？你觉得他们是怎么解决这个问题的？
That would be a way to get them to think about the aspect of the content that I think was meant to be the focus. You talk about another technique called elaborative interrogation. What is this Dan and how does it work? This is a technique to improve comprehension and also improve memory where as you're reading something you pose questions to yourself and try to answer the questions. It's even more effective if before you start reading the text, you actually look ahead a little bit and make some predictions about what you think you're likely to learn when you read this text and then pose questions based on that little preview that you do.
这就能引导他们去思考那些本该成为重点的内容。你提到了另一种叫做“精细加工审问法”的技术。丹，这是什么？它是如何运作的？这是一种提高理解力和记忆力的方法，即在你阅读某些内容时，向自己提出问题并试图回答这些问题。如果在开始阅读文本之前，稍微向前看一看，对阅读可能学到的内容做一些预测，然后根据这个简短的预览提出问题，效果会更好。
And then when you're reading the text, you're thinking about, did I pose good questions? Is this actually what the text is about? And if it is, what are the answers to those questions? And if it's not, what are some better questions? So it's a wonderful technique. There's lots and lots of research backing it as a way to prevent that sort of mindless reading, that sort of drift of attention as you're reading something, and keep your mind really focused. I mean, in all of this in some ways goes back to that idea we talked about, which is that we remember what it is we're mentally engaged with.
然后，当你在阅读文本时，你就会思考：我提出的问题好吗？这真的是文本的主题吗？如果是的话，这些问题的答案是什么？如果不是，有什么更好的问题吗？所以这是一个绝妙的技术。有大量研究支持它，认为它可以防止那种无意识的阅读，防止在阅读时注意力飘忽不定，并让你的思维真正集中。从某种程度上说，这一切其实都回到了我们之前讨论过的那个观点，即我们记住的是我们精神上投入的东西。
And so if you want to remember things, you have to find ways to actually engage with the material, not just simply be a passive recipient for it, but actually think about it, engage it, probe it, try and see the connections between that and other ideas, contest it, argue with it. That's the way you actually remember the material, not just simply listening to it. That's absolutely right. And these little tricks, I think, help because again, one of the things that's it's hard to do is sort of tell yourself Okay, now I'm really gonna think deeply about this. You need something more concrete
所以，如果你想记住事情，你必须找到真正参与到材料中的方法，而不仅仅是被动地接受它，而是真正去思考它、接触它、探究它、试着找出它与其他想法之间的联系、质疑它、反驳它。这才是真正记住材料的方法，而不仅仅是听着。完全正确。而且我认为这些小技巧很有帮助，因为正如我所说，很难做到的一点就是告诉自己：“好吧，现在我要真正深入思考这件事情了。”你需要更具体的东西。
So the technique like well, you know, look at the subheadings and try and generate some questions based on that That gives the mind something to work with where you see what the path forward is Instead of just telling people well really think about what it means. Another way of harnessing meaning is to frame the information that you're processing in the form of a story. Tell me about this idea, Dan. Yes, stories are very effective because stories have connections, stories have causality in them. It's in the nature of stories that event B was caused by event A. And so you can think about when there's content that you would like to master, thinking of whether or not it fits well into a story context can be a really effective way of
所以像这样的技巧，你知道的，看看小标题并试着根据它们生成一些问题，这会给大脑提供一些可以着手处理的东西，让你看到前进的方向，而不是仅仅告诉人们“好好想想它的意思”。另一种利用意义的方法是将你正在处理的信息构建成一个故事。丹，跟我讲讲这个想法。是的，故事非常有效，因为故事有联系，故事里面有因果关系。事件B是由事件A引起的，这是故事的本质。因此，当你有一些想要掌握的内容时，想想它是否适合放入故事的背景中，这可以成为一种非常有效的
organizing it. And I understand there's been research that has tested when people get information just as information and when people get information in the form of a story, there are differences in how well people remember the information. Yeah, absolutely. It's very clever experiments where they took basically the same set of facts that they were hoping to impart to the people who are going to be reading it. And some people read what you would just think of as a straightforward expository essay that laid out the facts. And then other people had the same facts sort of shaped into a story format.
组织方式。我听说过这样一项研究，它测试了人们将信息作为单纯信息接收，与将信息作为故事接收时，对信息的记忆效果是否存在差异。是的，绝对有。这是一个非常巧妙的实验，他们采用了基本上相同的一组事实，希望传授给阅读的人。一些人阅读了你所认为的直白陈述事实的说明文。而另一些人则将相同的事实塑造成了故事的形式。
Again, the emphasis within the story was on causality, connections among these various pieces. And what they found was that people who read it in a story format remembered the information better. And in some ways, I think this speaks to the idea that what you are talking about is really not just discrete pieces of information, but the architecture of how all this information fits together. And of course, in a well-constructed story, you don't just have a whole bunch of discrete pieces this information fits together. And of course, in a well-constructed story, you don't just have a whole bunch of discrete pieces of information, you actually have the entire architecture
同样，故事中的重点在于因果关系以及各个部分之间的联系。他们发现，以故事形式阅读的人对信息的记忆效果更好。在某些情况下，我认为这说明了这样一个观点：你所讨论的其实不仅是零散的信息，而是所有这些信息如何组合在一起的架构。当然，在一个精心构建的故事中，你拥有的不仅仅是一堆零散的信息如何组合在一起。当然，在一个精心构建的故事中，你拥有的不仅仅是一堆零散的
of the Lego building, if you will, with all the pieces sort of connected to one another. So to identify, when you're asked to identify any individual piece, you have a sense of where it sits in the overall scheme. Absolutely. I mean, the connections are so important. And I mean, every day evidence about this. Think about the last time someone, you went to a movie. And the next day someone asked you, oh, you saw that movie. What was that about? No one ever says, oh, I don't
乐高积木式的建筑架构（如果你愿意这么比喻的话），所有积木都彼此相连。因此，当你被要求识别任何单个零件时，你对于它在整体方案中的位置会有所感知。绝对是的。我的意思是，这些联系太重要了。关于这一点，我们每天都能看到证据。想想你上次去看电影的那次经历。第二天有人问你：“哦，你看过那部电影了。讲的是什么？”从来没有人会说：“哦，我不知道
know, like I didn't study it. You know, I just saw it. I didn't, right? I can't remember it. Right? No. The memory just comes for free when you're engaged with a story. And it is, as you say, it's all these Lego pieces fitting together because that's so intrinsic to the way memory works. You remember things based on cues. You get a hint. I say this and then, I say salt that makes you think of pepper. These two things are connected in memory. So in a story, everything is connected to something else.
，就像我没研究过一样。你知道的，我刚看了。我记不住，对吧？”不。当你投入到一个故事中时，记忆就会自然而然地出现。而且正如你所说，这就是所有乐高积木组合在一起的方式，因为这太符合记忆运作的内在规律了。你根据线索来记忆事物。你得到了一个提示。我说这个，然后我说盐，这就会让你联想到胡椒。这两件事在记忆中是相连的。所以在故事中，每件事都与其他事物相连。
So it's sort of like at the beginning of the story, it's like you're pulling out this very fine chain and the little pieces of the story are like little charms attached to the chain. You just keep tugging and it keeps coming out. It's easy to remember. You and others have talked about different elements in stories that are worth thinking about. If we wanted to construct stories to remember things, what are these elements that we should focus on then? Conflict is the way it's usually
所以这有点像在故事开始时，你拉出一条非常精细的链子，故事的小片段就像挂在链子上的小饰品。你只要一直拽，它就会不断出来。这很容易记住。你和其他人都讨论过故事中值得思考的不同元素。如果我们想构建故事来记住事情，那么我们应该关注哪些元素呢？冲突是故事结构中通常的描述方式。
described in story structure. So in Star Wars, you know, is Luke going to be able to save the civilization by destroying the death star, he needs something to fight against, so it's going to be Darth Vader. With our combined strength, we can end this destructive conflict and bring order to the galaxy. I'll never join you. And then there, again, when you're thinking about story structure, you're usually thinking about multiple pieces.
所以，在《星球大战》中，你知道的，卢克能通过摧毁死星来拯救文明吗？他需要一个对抗的目标，那就是达斯·维达。通过我们联合的力量，我们可以结束这场破坏性的冲突，给银河系带来秩序。我绝不会加入你。然后，再次强调，当你思考故事结构时，你通常会考虑多个部分。
So the other aspect in addition to conflict is complications. So the first try at the solution to the problem that you've figured out usually doesn't work for one reason or another. That's a complication. Then there's a sub problem that you have to figure out. And again, that makes for very nice connections that helps you sort of keep it all organized in your mind and easier to remember. Can you want to talk about the role that characters play in our memories, the characters that we encounter in stories would seem to be an important component of what makes stories memorable?
因此，除了冲突之外的另一个方面是 komplikations（波折）。也就是说，对你找出的问题的解决方案的第一次尝试，通常由于某种原因行不通。这就是一个波折。然后还有一个你需要弄清楚的子问题。同样，这造就了非常好的联系，有助于你在脑海中将所有内容组织得井井有条，更容易记住。你想谈谈角色在我们的记忆中扮演的角色吗？我们在故事中遇到的角色似乎是使故事令人难忘的一个重要组成部分？
Absolutely. And again, if there are people in what you're trying to remember, that's going to be really helpful. Individual personalities, help, distinctiveness helps memory, things that stand out because they're unlike other things that you've encountered. That's a very general principle of memory that things that are really distinctive are much easier to remember. So, if you've got individual people, then that's great. If you don't have individual people, you can still think of something analogous in your story where sort of the action is. I was describing this to a physicist and immediately said, energy in any physical system, I was
绝对是的。同样，如果你试图记住的东西里面有人物，那将会非常有帮助。独特的个性有助于记忆，与众不同有助于记忆，那些因为与你遇到的其他事物不同而脱颖事物的特征更容易被记住。这是记忆的一个非常普遍的原则，那些非常独特的事物要容易记住得多。所以，如果你有个体人物，那太棒了。如果没有个体人物，你仍然可以在你的故事中找到类似的东西，也就是行动发生的地方。我曾向一位物理学家描述过这一点，他立刻说，任何物理系统中的能量，我都会
look for the energy because that's where the action is going to be. And I don't know enough physics to really evaluate whether or not that was right, but his eyes lit up when he was telling me that. So that's a way of thinking about the role of character, not just in stories where they're actually people, but in other types of stories as well. And I'm thinking about plays or movies, you know, you know, a movie like, you know, a beautiful mind, I think, did far more to popularize the ideas of John Nash, the mathematician than any number of mathematics textbooks. Hamilton, the play, probably did more for US history and American history and
寻找能量，因为行动将会在那里发生。我对物理学的了解还不足以真正评估这是否正确，但他当时眼睛发亮地向我讲述着。所以这就是思考角色作用的一种方式，不仅在有真人的故事中，在其他类型的的故事中也是如此。我想到了戏剧或电影，你知道的，像《美丽心灵》这样的电影，我认为它在普及数学家约翰·纳什的想法方面，起到的作用远远超过了任何数量的数学教科书。戏剧《汉密尔顿》在推动美国历史、美国历史以及
people, students understanding American history than countless history classes. Yes, those were beautiful examples of character-driven stories. So, sometimes down the information we have to memorize is not in itself very meaningful. So let's say you're trying to remember the names of all the presidents of the United States. There's obviously no meaning to the names. There's no story to connect all the names together. What do we do? The go-to method here is a namanic. And the namanics are ways of lending meaning to something that doesn't have any meaning, or other times it's
学生对美国历史的理解方面，所起的作用可能超过了无数的历史课。是的，这些都是以人物为主导的故事的美妙例子。有时候，我们必须记住的信息本身并不是很有意义。比方说，你正试图记住所有美国总统的名字。这些名字显然没有任何意义。没有一个故事能把所有的名字串联起来。我们该怎么做？这里首选的方法是助记法。助记法是赋予原本没有任何意义的事物以意义的方法，或者有时候是
another sort of a trick that helps the information become easier to pull out of memory. Have you done this? Are they mnemonics that you still remember from your childhood? Absolutely. And my in junior year of high school, my teacher asked all of us to memorize the U.S. Presidents in order and taught us a little mnemonic song to commit them to memory. I'm going to put you on the spot here, Dan. Let's give it a go. Wajma J.V. Hut Putt Fumpul, J.G. H.A.C. H.C. McRue, Tawu, Haku, Hu Rue, Trimican, John X Ford, Karagan Bush. MacRue, Tawu, Haku, Huru, Trimican, John X Ford, Carrigan, Bush. And what is that stand for?
另一种有助于将信息从记忆中更容易提取出来的技巧。你做过这个吗？有没有哪些助记法是你从童年一直记到现在的？当然有。在我高三那年，我的老师要求我们按顺序背诵美国总统，并教了我们一段小助记歌把它刻进记忆里。丹，我要让你当众出丑了。我们来试试吧。Wajma J.V. Hut Putt Fumpul, J.G. H.A.C. H.C. McRue, Tawu, Haku, Hu Rue, Trimican, John X Ford, Karagan Bush. MacRue, Tawu, Haku, Huru, Trimican, John X Ford, Carrigan, Bush. 那代表什么意思？
I'm sort of starting to pick up the outlines of the names there. Yeah. So it's the first letter of each president's name. So it starts Wajima. So Wajima is Washington, Adams, Jemah, Jefferson, Madison, Monroe, Adams, J.V. Jackson, Van Buren. And then occasionally, you have to remember some things. So like, Trumiken is Truman, and then Ike for Eisenhower, and then it ends Ken for Kennedy.
我开始能看出这些名字的轮廓了。是的。这是每个总统名字的第一个字母。所以它以 Wajima 开头。所以 Wajima 是华盛顿、亚当斯、杰斐逊（Jemah）、杰斐逊、麦迪逊、门罗、亚当斯、J.V. 杰克逊、范布伦。然后偶尔，你必须记住一些事情。比如，Trumiken 是杜鲁门，然后 Ike 代表艾森豪威尔，然后以肯尼迪的 Ken 结尾。
So there are little bits in there. We have to do some interpretation. But of course, that's not hard. And I will say, I probably recite that little rhyme to myself once or twice a year. When for some say, I probably recite that little rhyme to myself once or twice a year, when for some reason I'm trying to think, now, who is probably present at that point? Needless to say, you have to be kind of quiet when you do it. It's socially, it's a little awkward. So we've talked about how easy it is for us to feel a sense of familiarity with a given set of facts,
所以里面有一些小片段。我们必须做一些解释。当然，这并不难。而且我要说的是，我大概每年会对自己背诵那一小段韵文一两次。当因为某种原因我试图去想，现在，当时可能是哪位总统在任？不用说，你做这件事的时候必须保持安静。在社交场合，这有点尴尬。所以我们讨论过，我们对一组给定的事实产生熟悉感是多么容易，
but instead of familiarity, you suggest that we need to adopt a new standard of what it means to know something, something that can overcome our illusion of explanatory depth, where we believe we know things better than we actually know them. What is the technique that you suggest? Most of the time, the technique is going to be posing the question to yourself and seeing whether or not you can explain it. I would elaborate on this a little bit. I would say that the technique you use to test your memory should be a good fit for what you actually want to be able to do with the information. So for example, this happens, comes up a lot in the context of mathematics.
但你建议我们不要仅仅满足于熟悉感，而是需要采纳一个关于了解某事物的新标准，这个标准能够克服我们对解释深度的错觉，在这种错觉中，我们以为自己对事物的了解比实际情况要好。你建议的技术是什么？大多数时候，这种技术就是向自己提出问题，看看你是否能够解释它。我会对此做一点详细说明。我会说，用来测试记忆的技术应该非常适合你实际想要用这些信息做什么。例如，这种情况在数学领域经常出现。
Students will learn a particular formula to solve a particular type of problem. And they learn it in the context of a word problem that's to do with football players, for example. And then on the test, the same principle is tested. They need to use the same formula, but now it's not football players. Now it's automobiles or something else.
学生会学习特定的公式来解决特定类型的问题。他们是在一个以橄榄球运动员为例的应用题背景下学习它的。然后在考试中，测试的是同一个原理。他们需要使用相同的公式，但现在不再是橄榄球运动员了。现在是汽车或其他东西。
And they fail to recognize the information. This is a different type of recognition, and it's actually much more difficult. So memory tends to cling to the examples that we initially encountered. So you need to think about what am I actually wanting to do with this information? Do I need to be able to just describe it to others? That's what we talked about as being more difficult than just recognizing it. Or do I need to be able to recognize it in new guises, that's still more difficult. So take the problem that was about football and take the problem that was about automobiles.
他们却没能认出这些信息。这是另一种类型的识别，实际上要困难得多。因此，记忆往往依附于我们最初遇到的例子。所以你需要思考：我实际上想用这些信息做什么？我需要能够把它描述给别人听吗？这就是我们所说的比单纯识别更困难的事情。还是我需要在新的伪装下识别它？这甚至更难。所以把关于橄榄球的问题和关于汽车的问题拿出来。
Take those two problems that look different on the surface and then describe how are these actually similar? And Chunker, this actually follows the principle that you and I have been talking about before, which is that memory sort of follows thought. What you're getting yourself to do by comparing those problems is, thinking about what they have in common, you're thinking about that deep structure that they share. And so that's going to make you better appreciate that deep structure and be able to remember and recognize it later in new problems. You know, so much of what we've been talking about, I think, goes back to that idea of
把这两个表面看起来不同的问题拿出来，然后描述它们实际上是如何相似的？而“组块化”（Chunker），这实际上遵循了你和我之前一直在讨论的原则，即记忆某种程度上遵循思维。通过比较这些问题，你促使自己去做的，是思考它们的共同点，思考它们共享的深层结构。因此，这将使你更好地理解这种深层结构，并能够在以后遇到新问题时记住并识别它。你知道，我们讨论过的很多内容，我认为都回到了那个理念上，即
of almost probing our minds to find, you know, the weaknesses, to find the broken links in the chain. And that is just so hard to do, isn't it? Because it's sort of constantly exposing us to the limits of our own knowledge, the limits of our own understanding. It's forcing us to do the difficult thing of doing, you know, the push-ups where you're trying to clap as you're doing the push-ups. I think I'm trying to intuit why it is so many of us,
几乎是在探究我们的大脑，以找出弱点，找出链条中断裂的环节。这实在是太难做到了，不是吗？因为它不断地将我们暴露在我们自身知识的局限、自身理解的局限面前。它强迫我们去做困难的事情，就像做俯卧撑时还要试着击掌一样。我想我是在试图直观地理解，为什么我们中有这么多人，
not only have bad memories, but why it's so difficult to fix those bad memories. It's just effortful. And I think it's hard to face up to it. It's not fun to say like, oh, there's a whole lot here that I don't know. There's a whole lot. Let me make a point of probing what I don't know.
不仅记忆力差，而且为什么修复这些糟糕的记忆会如此困难。这太费精力了。而且我认为很难去面对它。承认“哦，这里有太多我不知道的东西，有太多东西”一点也不好玩。让我明确去探究我不知道的东西。
Let me find my weaknesses. That takes, you know, ego strength to sort of be brave in that way and look at what we don't know. So even when we use very rigorous memory strategies, our memories may still fail us, and you have learned to use external aids to help your memory. I understand that in fact you might be a little obsessed with calendars and alarms. Can you tell me about your various practices involving calendars and alarms, Dan?
让我找出我的弱点。这需要自我力量，才能以那种方式变得勇敢，并审视我们不知道的事情。因此，即使我们使用了非常严格的记忆策略，我们的记忆仍然可能会让我们失望，而你已经学会使用外部辅助工具来帮助你的记忆。据我所知，你可能对日历和闹钟有点着迷。丹，你能跟我讲讲你涉及日历和闹钟的各种习惯吗？
Yeah, I'm obsessed is probably fair. My perspective memory is not very good. I don't remember to do things. And so the way I deal with that is I've made a real habit of relying on my calendar. If it's not on my calendar, the odds that I'm going to remember it are very, very close to zero. I also make heavy use of alarms that are programmed in my phone. In a typical day, I'll have eight alarms or something like that going. You have something going off at 11.25 to tell you something's happening at 11.30 pay attention?
是的，说我着迷大概挺公正的。我的前瞻性记忆不太好。我不记得去做事情。所以我处理这个问题的方法是养成了依赖日历的真实习惯。如果它不在我的日历上，我能记住它的概率几乎为零。我也大量使用手机上编程的闹钟。在典型的一天里，我会设置八个左右的闹钟。你是不是有个闹钟在11点25分响，提醒你11点30分有事发生，要集中注意力？
Yeah, I mean, again, this is sort of facing up to weakness. I just live too much in my head and I'm not aware enough of the world around me and so I need something to sort of snap me out of it. I understand that this habit of relying on external memory saved the day for you at one point a few years ago. Tell me that story, Dan.
是的，我的意思是，这再次体现了正视弱点。我只是活在自己的世界里太多了，对周围的世界不够关注，所以我需要某种东西来把我从这种状态中猛然拉醒。据我所知，几年前，这种依赖外部记忆的习惯曾在关键时刻拯救了你。丹，讲讲那个故事吧。
This is five years ago, maybe, and my wife had our three children out. They were all at an event that I was not at. This was on a Sunday. This is pretty unusual for me with three small children. And so I was really enjoying myself. I'm sort of puttering around the house and doing little chores as we do on Sunday. And then I start, decide I'm going to do a little work puttering. So I start answering email and so on. And then at some point I get an email where I need to put
那是五年前吧，我妻子带着我们的三个孩子出去了。他们都在一个我没去的活动上。那是一个星期天。这对于带着三个小孩子的我来说相当罕见。所以我当时过得很开心。我有点在家里闲晃，做着周日照例会做的小杂务。然后我开始决定一边闲晃一边做点工作。所以我开始回复电子邮件等等。然后不知何时我收到了一封邮件，我需要把它
them in my calendar. So I open my calendar and I still remember the feeling of opening my calendar and perceiving on that day a red blob, red means important. And it was one of those things where like time slows down and I'm like, that can't be right. And I go and look at what it is. And I realize I have an airplane I'm supposed to be on in 75 minutes. Oh my God. And the airplane, I was supposed to go to city in the Midwest and I'm supposed to be on in 75 minutes. Oh my God. And the airplane I was supposed to go to sitting in the Midwest and I was supposed to give a talk the next day. I wasn't packed.
们记在日历上。所以我打开日历，我依然记得打开日历时的感觉，看到那天有一个红色的圆点，红色代表重要。那种感觉就像时间变慢了，我在想：“这不可能是真的。”然后我去查看那是什么。我意识到我有一张飞机票，我必须在75分钟后登机。天哪。而那架飞机，我本该去中西部的一个城市，我必须在75分钟后登机。天哪。我本该去中西部的一个城市，第二天还要做演讲。我还没收拾行李。
I absolutely no idea what the talk was supposed to be that I was supposed to give. The airport's about a half an hour away. Oh my God. So sort of for my life, I threw things in a suitcase and it all ended up fine, but that was a very close call. Daniel Wilingham is a psychologist at the University of Virginia. He's the author of the book Outsmart Your Brain, while learning is hard and how you can make it easy. Dan, thank you so much
我完全不知道我该做演讲的内容是什么。机场大约半小时车程。天哪。为了我的生活，我把东西塞进手提箱，最后一切都顺利解决了，但那真是一次千钧一发的危机。丹尼尔·威林汉姆（Daniel Wilingham）是弗吉尼亚大学的心理学家。他是《超越大脑：为什么学习很难以及如何让它变得轻松》（Outsmart Your Brain）一书的作者。丹，非常感谢你
for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been a real pleasure, thank you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Brigitte McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is listener and hidden brain supporter, Robin Ross. Robin tells us that the unsung hero stories are one of her favorite parts of the show. She was particularly moved by the story of a woman named Jennifer, whose un-sung hero
今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。这真的是一段非常愉快的时光，谢谢你。本期《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里吉特·麦卡锡（Brigitte McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲·保尔（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯汀·黄（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是听众兼《隐藏的大脑》支持者罗宾·罗斯（Robin Ross）。罗宾告诉我们，无名英雄的故事是她最喜欢的节目部分之一。她特别被一个名叫詹妮弗（Jennifer）的女性的故事所感动，詹妮弗的无名英雄
stopped a group of girls from bullying her in middle school. Robin writes, ''Your un-sung hero stories reassure me that there is hope for us. Acts of kindness can have an enormously positive impact, and we should all try to be someone's un-sung hero.'' We're so glad you enjoyed these stories, Robin, and we should all try to be someone's unsung hero. We're so glad you enjoyed these stories Robin and we really appreciate your support. If you liked today's episode and if you'd like to join Robin in helping us make more hidden brain stories, please go to support.hiddenbrain.org.
阻止了一群女孩在初中时欺负她。罗宾写道：“你们的无名英雄故事让我确信我们还有希望。善举可以产生巨大的积极影响，我们都应该努力成为某人的无名英雄。”罗宾，我们很高兴你喜欢这些故事，我们都应该努力成为某人的无名英雄。罗宾，我们很高兴你喜欢这些故事，并且我们非常感谢你的支持。如果你喜欢今天的节目，并且如果你想加入罗宾的行列，帮助我们制作更多《隐藏的大脑》故事，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。
That site again is support. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. true Trimican Johnx Ford Carrigan Bush. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再次访问这个网址：support。我是香卡·维丹坦（Shankar Vedantam）。我们很快再见。真实的 Trimican Johnx Ford Carrigan Bush。[♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪ 这个剧集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。